hi I'm Erik Bosse and detective Pikachu
is in many ways the live-action Pokemon
film Pokemon fans like me I've wanted
and even if the movie seemed more aimed
at kids I also spent hundreds of dollars
on us spider-man costumes in Infinity
Gauntlet so shut up and let me love my
toys Pokemon sightings are all over this
damn movie but rather than play you know
Pokemon snap and point out all 40 of the
squirtles that we already saw in this
video I'm gonna break down the more
interesting easier to miss nods to the
Pokemon franchise the real reasons that
nerds like us like this movie by the way
don't get mad at me if I pronounced a
Pokemon name differently than you do I
was just a sad little boy growing up
playing these games all by myself with
no one to correct me when I called it a
rat-a-tat-tat spoiler warning if you
haven't seen detective Pikachu yet and
let's get started okay in the first act
we meet the hero Tim Goodman played by
Justice Smith he's with his buddy played
by Karin Soni
dopinder from the Deadpool movies also
with Ryan Reynolds they're trying to
catch Tim his first Pokemon a cubone
who's wailing in the middle of the field
missing its mom they're referencing the
original super dark pokedex description
of generation 1 which stated that cubone
wears the skull of its dead mother they
joke here that key boned and Tim are
both mourning their dead moms Oh
Tim's shirt features the lettering of
the alphabet Pokemon known he wears
different unknown shirts throughout the
movie this one for the unknown letter H
which is associated with the words help
or heal reflecting Tim's brokenness
early in the movie and later one for Oh
like for the word one as in the oneness
between trainers and their pokémon
partners when they're fused Tim takes
the train to Rhine city where a
promotional video explains that unlike
the rest of this pokemon world rhyme
city has no pokeballs no battles at
least legally that humans in Pokemon
lives side by side but the video also
depicts trainer red in a Coliseum red is
the hero that you play as in the gen 1
games from Pallet Town the champion of
Kanto defeater of Team Rocket that is
unless you're complete idiot and somehow
weren't able to complete that game look
Mount Moon's kind of hard to get through
if you get poisoned this video also
shows a quick shot of some squirtles
helping out put out a fire they're
called the squad a reference to the
squirtle squad from the animated series
fortunately none of them appear to be
wearing sunglasses listening closely to
the music in this promo video it's from
Lee Pokemon games actually throughout
this movie the composer uses Pokemon
music like during the Clifford
commercials from oh shoot and of course
when Pikachu said these things they
gotta catch it on the haul beam song now
rhyme city is spill
with Pokemon sightings I'm not gonna
bother pointing all of them because I'm
sure you saw a lot of them but to me the
most interesting one is Snorlax it's
blocking traffic with Machamp using its
multiple arms to redirect cars store
lacks blocking the road is the subtle
not of course of the games when Snorlax
blocks a few of the paths forcing you to
take different routes through Kanto Tim
heads into the rhine city police station
where the cops use groundless and are
canines just like Officer Jenny did in
the show and if you look at the
background outside the police station my
own Jean on the terrace back there it
see a slacking someone lazy ass Pokemon
Tim meets detective Yoshida Ken Watanabe
the name Yoshida could be a shout-out to
Hironobu Yoshida a graphic designer
instrumental to the Pokemon games and
back at Tim's dad's apartment the
building has a word oak on it a nod to
of course Professor Oak
inside there's a surprising reference
with the old gangster movie angels with
built these souls on the TV this isn't a
real movie it's a fake movie from home
alone that Kevin McCallister watches it
was a parody of the real film angels
with dirty faces kind of random that
this was in the movie inside the bedroom
that Tim's dad kept for him is a bunch
of nerdy Pokemon merch I swear I didn't
have any of this stuff battle posters a
Pikachu bed frame but also Tim has a
binder full of pokemon trainer cards
just like the binders that we use for
our pokemon cards after dumping out her
brother's dumb baseball cards and then
getting beaten up tim meets pikachu
voiced by ryan reynolds so funny in this
movie he accidentally releases a sample
of the are drug serum that drives these
a poms nuts this our drug is a nod to
rage the drug from the detective Pikachu
game though it's nefarious role
throughout this plot echoes the are logo
of Team Rocket the criminal enterprise
in the Pokemon universe
Tim learns that everyone else hears
Pikachu normally with Pikachu voiced
here by a cameo from Akio Thani
the beloved Pikachu voice actor and they
head to the high hat cafe another
location the detective Pikachu game
where they meet the monstrosity that is
Ludicolo translates to kill me please my
hat is a cactus in this cafe Jigglypuff
sings the guy to sleep singing the same
echo a Jigglypuff song from the series
Jigglypuff also uses a marker as a
microphone as it doesn't a series I'm
sure later on Jigglypuff make sure to
tag this guy's face this cafe also
features signs for a primate Machamp
fight and a sign for berry juice
which is a nod to the berries in gin to
berry juice for storing a pokemons HP
they visit this underground fighting
arena where loud Reds are used as
speakers they beat pucks so great
during this battle the announcer yells
take it down with one hit a line from
the original Pokemon Stadium game and
the tank has a Magikarp in it which
spills out when it breaks to defend
itself Magikarp uses flash which in the
game was the only move Magikarp could
use in general this movie is actually
really good about Pokemon using their
actual moves from the game mr. mime uses
barrier and u2 later uses recover
pikachu smartly knows that Magikarp
involves into Gyarados saying all it
takes is a little kick which is a joke
about how Team Rocket's James kicks
Pokemon and accidentally evolved them
just as he did with Magikarp at one
point at one point Pikachu jokes about
getting in his thousand steps which
feels looking odd - Pokemon go which
added a step tracker feature since you
know the game's whole point was really
to force us outside and work on me I
used a drone and seriously other phones
I cannot have fun if I sweat after some
hilarious charades with mr. mine Burnie
mr. mime alive ten visits Howard
Clifford Bill Nighy and in his office
there's a statue of legendary Pokemon
Arceus in the center is a god of the
Pokemon universe
Dialga on the left also a member of the
creation tree of sin oh he represents
time and Pacquiao on the right
representing space the office also has a
number of evolution stones including
what looks like a water stone and a nice
stone and what I previously thought was
a moon stone but it also looks like
maybe a piece of old amber or maybe a
king's Rock we also meet Clifford's
assistant who always wears sunglasses
because we find at the end of the movie
it is a ditto we actually saw this ditto
earlier during the promo shoot is
pushing Clifford's wheelchair dittos
female human form here has pink hair and
seems like kind of a sneaky villain
could be kind of a loose nod to Jessie
from Team Rocket so Tim Lucy pikachu and
psyduck drive out to the lab on Lucy's
dashboard is a spoink figurine and I
just love the detail that they included
Psyduck having migraines just like it
does in the animated series because it
uses confusion it's a psychic doc gets
headaches later Pikachu tries to calm
side up by repeating the phrase serenity
now there's a nod to the sitcom Seinfeld
it's the phrase mr. Costanza repeats to
calm down
in this lab they learned that Mewtwo
broke out of canto 20 years prior 20
years being a nod to
come on the movie Mewtwo strikes back
which came out around 20 years ago it
showed me to breaking out of captivity
later on it has revealed that Clifford
is using parade balloons to disperse the
are gas and mind-control Mewtwo defuse
every human with their pokémon partner
it's a crazy plot but it's foreshadowed
earlier by Clifford's dream of humans
and pokémon bean equals during the scene
Lucy takes the jacket a microphone of a
hotshot reporter and I might be wrong
about this but that actress at least
looked a lot like Veronica Taylor the
voice of ash in the animated series
could be a cameo from her it could just
be someone who looks like her the final
reveal of Pikachu actually being Tim's
father Harry played by live-action Ryan
Reynolds explains kind of why this movie
used Ryan Reynolds voice and not some of
the other voice actors we were really
hoping for like Danny DeVito like shirt
give me those voice would have been
perfect as this gruff detective but to
see Danny DeVito live-action show up at
the end might have felt a little weird
looking back at the movie that was super
interesting to see how this reveal was
set up in little discreet ways Lucy said
that she had never seen a Pokemon wear a
hat before this hat belonging to Harry
Goodman because this Pikachu actually
had the sole of that human detective Tim
wouldn't have recognized this voice as
his dad's because he had not seen or
talked to his dad in over ten years and
probably would have forgotten what his
dad sounded like and this Pikachu is
addicted to coffee the beverage of
choice for many detectives Harry even
references wanting to get a coffee at
the end and he could shoo says these
exact words my problem is I pushed
people away and then hate them for
leaving which is an emotion Pikachu
Harry probably woulda still felts about
himself despite having his memory wiped
because that is exactly what Harry did
to Tim he pushed his son away hated his
son for leaving but then felt that
lasting guilt comment down below with
your favorite moment from detective
Pikachu follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at ei vas and subscribe to new
rockstars here on YouTube for breakdowns
of everything you love can also find us
on podcast form on Westeros weekly and
inside marble for early access to all
that kind of coverage and up coming soon
exclusive to audio episodes
thank you for watching bye
[Music]